hey hey what's up fellow geeks welcome
to another quick unboxing this time we
have the sniper ghost warrior contracts
unboxing so this is an exclusive
media kit that was sent to us and yeah
let's i'm pretty sure there's a few
trinkets and items here that we can use
so let's hop to it
so the first thing you actually see is a
pvc patch
that uh there's the name of the game
pretty quality here in the backpack
itself there's so many pockets
so many straps and look that they have
attached
everything
onto it feels heavy it looks like
there's something inside as well
so let's take a look at the outside
exterior as well you got pocket one
pocket two
another
pocket inside another compartment here
as well
it's great for handling you can also
strap it
like so make it all nice and
tight you can probably put more things
as well
now we got a few things here so let's
start off with this this looks like a
head buff
or a scarf and let's check out the
design real quick we have the sniper
ghost warrior contracts too
nice digital camo
wow this is it's actually pretty quality
stuff man
yeah a pretty cool hit buff
awesome next thing we have is this looks
like some sort of
carabiner
um oh it's it
wow okay so it's a carabiner with
a usb as well i believe this is four
gigabytes
flash drive just hook it onto your
backpack and you don't bring it anywhere
next i believe we have something sort of
a
survival kit if you will
so you've got a
got a little
compass
here and this is i think this is like
bungee cord like parachute cord that you
can actually unravel and you know make
use of it while you're out there
surviving
so this itself this is like a mini can
opener as well
so if you take a look at here this is
a flint rod and you've got the thing to
scrap it so let's see whether i can make
some sparks right here
oh yeah
see that
that's pretty cool
next we have another thing over here
with this this attaches to the strap
here and this feels like you can open it
could be possible you want to hang a
water bottle this could work it's pretty
handy it's a very handy backpack
actually i'm very surprised next we have
another thing here
this looks like a piece kind of like a
braided fishing line too so it's gonna
be
great for survival it's not gonna you
know break or anything and the fish are
gonna have a hard time with that
yes
so you can really tell this whole
backpack
something to do with survival survival
kit if you will it's very interesting so
now we have all the
exterior stuff oh no we have more
actually wow okay so onto this side we
have a pen this is a very interesting
pen to be honest
so
what happens when you check it out it
feels like puzzles
okay so that's the ink
saying anything else it's like a
tactical pen i don't know can you jab
people with this or something what does
this this side do
that's what i want to know
yeah so in that sense this is just a
really rugged pen like a military
great pen a great grip you can puncture
people on this end and you know write
his death wish
on the other
hmm
all right and next thing we have here is
it's got to be a flashlight right
so yeah we have a very cool
flashlight
there's no batteries in it
can change the focus i think
let's put some batteries on this man
right so we got batteries inside
it's a pretty all right torchlight let's
see whether let's let's turn off the
lights a little bit here we go
yeah
that's pretty good
and it's telescopic so you can actually
focus
you know like a doctor
open your eyes please
but yeah very nifty
torchlight works well cool
there's a strobe effect too
great so now that we have all those out
of the way and nothing else to surprise
us let's open it up and try and find if
there's any more souvenirs so let's
check the top pocket here nope
but it's it's pretty cool because you
have some sort of like
waterproof layer
as well things already get wet as they
should
well nothing in the front pocket but you
got pretty good compartments too you can
put your passports and all your pens and
toothbrush if you need to this
compartment this front one here
oh
look at that looks like another pelican
case let's open it up i believe this is
like another survival case that we have
a
emergency blanket i'm sure we need this
more but hey you never know when you're
gonna get cold right
we have this cool thing uh it's a
it's a metal spock
hmm
really like
we don't we don't get a knife or
anything or what it's going oh okay so
here's an eye cheeky fellas spoon fork
and knife complete set
so
it's pretty sharp edge too
also have what seems to be a
card holder something it's like a
multi-tool i guess some manual here
multi-purpose pocket survival tool you
got a can opener knives screwdriver
ruler cap opener a four position wrench
for various sizes butterfly wrench saw
blade
direction ancillary indication two
position wrench and a lanyard full or
keyring hole
all right
oh yeah so so yes
[Music]
this side so you can see all you can see
all like there's a mini ruler
happy with that stainless steel as they
said interesting cool
see here
got
something else this could be another
flint rod
uh
tinder rod
oh yeah so it's it's tight together
there you go flint rod
and the striker slash ruler
slash can opener as well so a lot of
multi-users so i guess this is the only
way we should
check it out to see whether it works
right
there we go
i don't have to force it just help just
goes along
that's cool
man that's a shame congo campaign now
sad anyway i think this is the last bit
i think this is a it's a very primitive
in that sense fishing rod you got a
little fishing hook and
seems like a fake bait too
i wonder if you can actually catch fish
with this
cool and that's all for the pelican case
see what else we have here
aha so we have two things here
and one thing wrapped in a kind of a
camo bag
and it's a
it's a skull
half a skull at least to put something
in here of course again you got the name
of the game here
skull with a headshot bullet wound i
believe this could be a pencil or a pen
holder
not sure what 125 means could be
our batch of stuff at the center so
let's let's put the pen that's i think
that's what we need to do let's put the
pen here we go
it works
it works don't you want to see this and
the collector's edition do you think it
will be a fine collector's edition so
purposeful let us know in the comments
down below too
and i think last but not least we have
the
hoodie yeah that's about it so again a
hoodie it's a size
size l nothing much at the front but at
the back we have very cool sniper ghost
warrior print doesn't look like it's
gonna fade after a few washes so that's
that's pretty good quality right there
and the side too
we have another iron on patch
of the game
as well
thanks for sending this to us guys and
of course if you do want to check out
sniper ghost warrior contracts too well
the game
you can actually head over to our gaming
channel geek culture gaming we put in
the link in the description below
and yeah you guys can check out the game
for yourselves as well
let us know your thoughts in the
comments down below would you want to
get one for yourself do you wish this
probably came up with a collector's
edition or something like that
who knows so that's about it we hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did don't
forget to give us a thumbs up and if you
haven't already do consider subscribing
helps out the channel a lot and until
the next video we chat to you soon
see ya
[Music]
you